مساء الخير اهلا بكم بلا نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعنايه
امين
وجودي خبراء ميدانيين في اوكرانيا
ريه
شرق السعوديه تتضمن 19
تسريب يهدد بيانات نصف مليار مستخدم
للواتساب منهم 28 مليون مستخدم في
السعوديه
الرابعه ايضا
بالفعاليات العلا تبدا استقبال الزوار
حفله موسيقيه ومناطق مفتوحه
ومنتخبات اسيا توصل المفاجات في كاس
العالم ايران تهزم ويلز وقطر على محاكي
السنغال
في تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه جديده
على مواصلات دعم اوكرانيا في حربها
خلف شمال الاطلسي ليس لديه اي خبراء على
الارض في اوكرانيا
الى ان الوقت قد حان الانضمام
وفي تاثيرات الحرب الاوكرانيه على الفن
شرى المجلس الدولي للمتاحف قائمه حمراء
تضم ممتلكاتها ثقافيه معرضه للخطر في
اوكرانيا وذلك بهدف مكافحه الاتجار غير
المشروع بهذه الممتلكات والذي زادت وترته
مع الهجوم الروسي لاوكرانيا بحسب المجلس
المجلس الدولي للمتاحف عبر عن امله في ان
تشكل هذه القائمه مرجعا جيدا لتحديد
الممتلكات الثقافيه الموهوبه في اوكرانيا
موضحانا نتقارير حديثه اثبت التعرض متحف
خيرسون للفنون للنهب من القوات الروسيه
قناه توليا السفير الاوكراني في الرياض ان
بلاده تقدر كثيرا المساعدات التي قدمتها
السعوديه والتي بلغت عشره مليار 10 ملايين
ذهبت للاجئين الاوكرانيين السفير
الاوكراني في الرياضه ضاف بان المملكه
تقوم بجهد الانسانين كبير لمساعده الشعب
الاوكرانيه على مواجهه ازمه الشتاء مشيرا
الى ان هناك مساعده سعوديه اخرى بقيمه 400
مليون دولار ستصل الى اوكرانيا
ايام صعبه نتفهم ونقدر جدا العلاقه
والمساعدات التي قدمتها السعوديه
لاوكرانيا تم تقديم 10 ملايين دولار من
المساعدات الانسانيه للاجئين الاوكرانيين
مؤخرا اتخذ قرار باضافه 400 مليون دولار
كمساعدات اضافيه للشعب الاخرانيه لتوفير
المواد اللازمه والادويه والاهم كذلك هو
ان تلك المساعدات ستذهب لتوفير منتجات
بترول والغاز التي يحتاجها الاوكرانيون
بشده والذين يواجهون ظروفا شتويه صعبه
اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن اعتماد التوجه التنموي للجزيره
دارين وتاروت
والمبادرات المستقبليه للجزيره
يتضمن الاعلان تخصيص ميزانيه تقديرها
بقيمه مليارين
و644 مليون ريال فضلا عن انشاء مؤسسه
لتطوير جزيره دارين وتاروت تهدف المؤسسه
للارتقاء بجوده الحياه وتنميه الناتج
المحلي وذلك من خلال الاستفاده من الميزات
النسبيه للجزيره في النواحي التراثيه
والبيئيه وسياحيه بما يسهم في تحقيق
التنوع الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الخبراء الرئيس التنفيذي
لهيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه المهندس فهد
المطرب مهندس فهد حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه بدايه كلمنا عن المنطقه الشرقيه
بشكل عام يعني لماذا كان هذا المشروع
مشروع مشروع تطوير جزيره جرين وتاروت له
الاولويه لهيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه
شكرا
ايات الشكر والعرفان وعظيم الامتنان
لمقامه ولايه خادم الحرمين الشريفين سمو
سيدي ولي العهد
وصاحب السمو الملكي رئيس المجلس ونائب
رئيس المجلس رئيس اللجنه التنفيذي على
الدعم وهمم
وحرصهم على تقدم مسيره الاعمال في الهيئه
وفي المنطقه الشرقيه بشكل عام
المنطقه الشرقيه تزخر بتنوع جميل تنوع
ثقافي واجتماعي
وايضا تنوع وعمراني همم يعني يجب الوقوف
عنده كان لابد انه نعمل الدراسات اللازمه
همم التركيز على هذه الجوانب اللي هي
جوانب قوه هو همم يعني توفر فرصه واحده في
المنطقه الشرقيه
فيما يخص طبعا همم
تطوير جزيره دارين وتاروت والمشروع اللي
انطلاق
بموافقه كريمه من صاحب السمو الملكي اييي
الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد هو باكوره
الاعمال والمبادرات الاستراتيجيه اللي
قامت فيها هيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه بعد
الانتهاء من دراسه الوضع الراهن في
المنطقه الشرقيه بشكل عام فاا الجزيره
يعني تتميز همم
مكتسبات وفرص واعده سواء كانت على الصعيد
الاجتماعي او البيئي او حتى على صعيد
النسيج العمراني المميز في الجزيره وبعض
الاصول التاريخيه همم والثقافيه اللي
موجود طيب ما الذي سيتغير بالنسبه لهذه
الجزيره همم بالنسبه لسكان هذه الجزيره
ايضا
وتروت بعد اقرار انشاء هذه المؤسسه
المعنيه بالتطويرها
الدراسه طبعا بعد ما تنتهينا من عمل
دراسات الوضع الراحل للجزيره
كانت واضحه بالنسبه لنا المقاومات اللي
موجوده في الجزيره وكانت توجيه من البدايه
ان يتم التركيز على همم تعزيز الهويه
الخاصه بالجزيره والمحافظه على همم الاصول
اللي موجوده والتنوع اللي موجود وتعظيم
الفائده منها همم يعني كوجهه جاذبه
بالمنطقه الشرقيه ال- همم اللي بيتغير في
الجزيره ان الدراسه وتوجهات التنمويه بشكل
عام استهدفت ثلاث ركائز اساسيه همم
الحفاظ على البيئه
وتعزيز الجوانب البيئيه ودعمها وركيزه
اخرى اللي هي ركيزه المحافظه على الارث
التاريخي الموجود في الجزيره همم بشكل عام
سواء من خلال تاهيل بعض الاصول والمباني
التاريخيه والركيزه الثالثه هي ر اذا ترك
يعني تعظم جانب جوده الحياه
وتنويع همم الانشطه اللي موجوده سواء كانت
رياضيه او ثقافيه او اجتماعيه همم طبعا
كثير راح يتغير في الجزيره يعني بشكل همم
تدريجي باذن الله مواضيع تخصص الجوانب
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
للافضل باذن الله تعالى في برامج همم
محدده في همم لتطوير الجزيره عبر توجهات
ومن خلال توجهات عامه وباذن الله ستشهد
الجزيره ازدهار وانطلاقه جميله جدا باذن
الله تعالى
ما المده الزمنيه المتاحه للشهيد المشروع
همم يعني متى سيبدا العمل الفعل على تطوير
ولماذا يعني تم انشاء هذه المؤسسه المؤسسه
غير الربحيه يعني لماذا لم تكن
اشكرك على السؤال خالد اولا اجاوبك على
لماذا ليست
لماذا المؤسسه مؤسسه غير ربحيه التركيز
ماهو على الربحيه الحقيقه
ويعني الانفاق الحكومي على هذه المشاريع
مشاريع البنيه التحتيه على على نطاق
الواسع بهذا الحجم غالبا لا نستعد لا
تستهدف المملكه الربحيه من خلال هذا
المشروع ولا العوائد الماليه من خلال هذا
المشروع وانما تستهدف الجانب جانب التحفيز
الاقتصادي
ويجاد برامج همم محفزه لقاعده الاقتصاديه
اللي موجود
ايضا تحفيز القطاع همم الخاص سواء على
المستوى القطاع اللي هو المنشات الصغيره
والمتوسطه واشراك المجتمع في برامج متنوعه
همم تعزز من جانب جوده الحياه ايضا
المشاريع البنا التحتيه بشكل عام اصلا
يعني همم مردودها المالي طويل الاجل بشكل
عام ولكنها هي قاعده انطلاق وقاعده تمكين
بكثير من الاعمال اللي راح تمكن القطاع
الخاص وراح تمكن اهالي الجزيره وسكان
الجزيره واهالي المنطقه الشرقيه والزوار
والبدايه وبدايه التنفيذ وبدايه العمل
لمده الزمنيه سريعه
نستهدف باذنه تعالى ان ننطلق بالاعمال هذه
خلال همم عام 23 انطلاقه فعليه همم تبدا
طبعا بدراسات التفصيليه وصولا الى التنفي
باذن
موفقين شكرا جزيلا لك على تواجدك معنا من
الخبر الرئيسيه
المهندس فؤاد
المنطقه الشرقيه
حذيفه عادل
حذيفه مرحبا بك
اولا كيف تصور لنا طبيعه الاوضاع الان
فيرسون بعد الانسحاب الروسي
تحياتي خالد يعني في الحقيقه الاوضاع اقل
ما يمكن ان توصل به انها ماساويه
المواطنين يعيشون هنا وضعا صعبا جدا
المدينه تفتقد الى الكهرباء الى الكهرباء
والمياه والغاز والتدفئه وحتى شبكه
الاتصالات نحن مضطرين ان نكون في مباشره
من هذا المكان لانه المكان الوحيد الذي
فيه يعني شبكه شبكه اتصال ضعيفه جدا كما
تشاهد هنا هؤلاء المواطنين ياتون الى هنا
ليستطيع التواصل مع من يرغبون في التواصل
معه خارج هذه المدينه كما تشاهد همم هنا
يقفون يحاولون استخدام الهواتف والتحدث
الى اهلهم والى اصدقائهم خارج المدينه قبل
قليل تحدث الى همم يعني شو هو الحاكم في
هذه
المقاطعه الحاكمه العسكري في المقاطعه همم
يعني منذ الامس حتى اليوم كان هنالك حوالي
34 جريحا وس فقط لا نتيجه الضربات
الصاروخيه
والقذائف التي سقطت في المدينه قبل دقائق
قليله فقط كان هنالك القديم فسقطا بالقرب
من المتجر الوحيد الذي يعمل ويمكن
المواطنين على حصول منه على المواد
الغذائيه سقطايفه قتل شخص بالقرب من
المتجر كان يقف الشرضيه طارت واصابه هذا
المواطن وقتل في هذه الحادثه همم يعني
الوضع صعب جدا في المدينه قبل قليل ايضا
ناشد المواطنين هناك هذه الساحه عن يحاول
ان ينتقلوا الى مدن قريبه من هنا يعني
يكون فيها بعض الخدمات قال من لا يستطيع
ان ينتقل ان يستطيع ان نوفر له السكن على
نفقه الدوله والاطعام وايضا الترحيل يمكن
ان يكون على نفقه الدوله ناشد المواطنين
بانها المدينه ما زالت غير امنه كنا في
دوله قبل قليل يعني شاهدنا المناطق التي
تضرر في المدينه هنالك دمار واسع في هذه
المدينه هنالك مناطق كثيره ما زالت ملغمه
والقوات غير قادره الان اول المتخصصين غير
قادرين على تفكيك الالغام في جميع هذه
المناطق هم يعملون في المناطق التي يكون
فيها احتكاك مباشر للمواطنين او تواجد
للمدنين دائرهكون الاماكن الاخرى
والمؤسسات الاخرى لوقت لاحق لان العدد
قليل وايضا لا يوجد فنيين بالقدر الكافي
مقابل العدد همم من همم هذه ايضا كنا قبل
قليل في المناطق التي تواجد فيها القوات
الروسيه والقوات السودانيه ومركز القياده
ايضا وجدنا طبعا الاثار هناك وجدنا
المستشفى الذي كان يعني يجون فيه الجرح
وكل شيء خلفه وغادروا بعد ان قامت القوات
الروسيه عفوا القوات الاوكرانيه بقص هذا
المكان من انظمه هذه مارش كما الجنود
المتواجدين هناك في هذا المكان شكرا عادل
في الرابع بعد قليل نمو كبير للصادرات
العمانيه غير النفطيه خلال اغسطس الماضي
قيمتها تقدر بنحو خمسه مليارات ريال عماني
اهلا بكم من جديد
ارتفاعا قدر بنسبه
48.6% لتبلغ قيمتها اربعه مليارات اكثر من
84 مليارات ريال عماني بنهايه شهر اغسطس
الماضي حازت المنتجات والمعدنيه لقيمه
الاكبر من الصادرات الصناعيه غير النفطيه
لتبلغ حتى نهايه اغسطس الماضي ما قيمتها
اكثر من مليار ريال عماني ثلاثه منتجات
المعادن العاديه مصنوعاتها بقيمه صادرات
تصل الى اكثر من مليار ريال عماني
من مسقط ينضم الينا وفد العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي اهلا عبد الرحمن يعني اولا
ماذا تعني هذه الارقام بالنسبه لعمان
خالد اهلا وسهلا بك هل هذه ارقام تعني
تعافي كبير في الاقتصاد العماني لاسيما
بعد جائعه تكون لا ننسى ان عمان لديها
موقع استراتيجي مميز فهي البوابه الجنوبيه
للخليج العربي ومضيق هرمز الذي تدخل منه
الكثير من البضائع الى دول الخليج همم
ايضا هذا المضيق مقابل لموانع عمان سابع
زميلي وليد ياخذ لكم بعض اللقطات نحن الان
نقف امام همم ميناء مسقط هذا الميناء
التاريخي الذي تحول الى وجه سياحيه بعد
نقل العشره التجاريه الى ميناء صحار
الصناعي هناك موانئ كثيره خالد في عمان
اذا ما تحدثنا عن ميناء صلاله الذي يعد من
ابرز الموانئ العالميه ايضا بناء الدقم
الذي بدا في 2011 بتشغيل التجريبي للحوض
الجاف وبدا بتصنيع السفن ايضا عندك بناء
صحار ايضا الذي يبعد 240 كيلو تقريبا على
العاصمه العمانيه من خصب الذي يقع في
مسندم ايضا همم مقابل للموانع الايرانيه
وايضا همم يعتبر من احد المداخل الرئيسيه
الى موانع قطر والبحرين والكويت بالاضافه
الى طبعا من شناص هناك تعافي كبير
اقتصاديه مهم جدا اذا ما تحدثنا بالارقام
خالد وعن الوالدات تحديدا المنافذ البحريه
استحودت على اهم صادرات العمانيه والقيمه
الاعلى من اجمالي الواردات السلعيه لعمان
بنهايه اغسطس الماضي سجلت سبعه مليار ريال
عماني اي تقريبا 70 مليار سعودي والمنافذ
الجويه ايضا ضمت حوالي 901 مليون ريال
عماني هناك تعافي كبير ايضا على قطاع
السياحي نحن الان من امام سوق مطرح الشعبي
هذا السوق الذي يمتد عمره لاكثر من 200
عام لاحظ الحركه الاقتصاديه يعني ايضا
ملابس انتباهي خالد العدد الكبير من
السياح والعله كاس العالم في قطر ايضا
الكثير من السياح للقدوم الى سلطنه عمان
خاصه ان السلطات العمانيه اتاحت لمن يحمل
بطاقه هيا بالدخول الى الاراضي العمانيه
بدون تاشيره فهذا شجع الكثير من السياح
ايضا خاصه الاوروبيين والفود الاوروبيه ان
تزور عمان خاصه ان تقريبا ساعه ودقائق
بسيطه عن الدوحه هناك ايضا خطط استراتيجيه
بالنسبه لرؤيه عمان 20 40 لمحاوله ضخ
المزيد من الاستثمارات في القطاع
الاقتصادي والسياحي وايضا المزيد من
الواردات والصادرات ايضا خاصه الصناعات
البتروكيماويه وايضا المشتقات النفطيه
فيما يتعلق بسلطنه همم عمان هناك ايضا
تفاعل كبير يبدين محللين اقتصاديين تجاه
الاقتصاد العماني خلال الفتره القليله
المقبله لا سيما في ظل همم التغيرات همم
التشريعات الاقتصاديه المهمه اتخذتها
حكومه عمان خلال الفتره القليله الماضيه
للتعافي من جائحه كورونا وما نتبعها ايضا
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في اطار الخطه
المعتمده يعني لتنميه التطوير الاقتصاد
العماني الى اي مدى ممكن ان يكون هذا عامل
فاعل بالاضافه طبعا للاستفاده من موقع
الجغرافيا
كذلك في كل ما يتعلق تقريبا بصادرات غير
النفطيه في عمان
سلطنه عمان على تعزيز الشركات مع الدول
يعني عمان هي شريك من اهم الشركاء مثلا
اليابان الى جانب الصين كوريا الجنوبيه
ايضا الهند هناك ايضا استفاده كبيره من
موانع عمان الموجوده على امتداد الساحل
الخليج العربي وايضا موقع عمال استراتيجي
جعل الكثير من الدول تبادل الى عقد شركات
مع سلطنه عمان الى جانب ايضا خالد الحرص
الكبير من الحكومه العمانيه على التوظيف
الشباب العماني نعرف ان سلطنه عمان كانت
همم هناك لديها مشاكل فيما يتعلق
بالباحثين عن العمل والعدد الكبير للشباب
لكن رؤيه 20 40
ساهمت بحد كبير في توظيف الكثير من
العمانيين الاسبوع الماضي يحتفلت عمان
بعيدها الوطني ومن خلال هذه الاعياد تم
الاعلان عن عشره مشاريع استراتيجيه عمانيه
من المتوقع ان توظف الاف الشباب العمانيين
خلال السنوات القليله المقبله لا بالاضافه
الى طبعا رؤيتها الطموح الاقتصاديه لتعزيز
الشركات مع مع العديد من الدول التي همم
ربما تضخ الكثير من الاستثمارات داخل
السلطه
شكرا جزيلا لك من مسقط منفذ العربيه عبد
الرحمن
قال قائلا ما يسكر رئيس التنفيذي لشركه
تويتر ان الخطه الجديده لتوثيق الحسابات
على تويتر بمختلفيا ستبدا خلال الايام
واوضح ان المنصه ستستخدم الوان مختلفه
لتوثيق حسابات المنظمات والافراد وسيتم
اعتماد توثيق اللون الذهبي للشركات
والرمادي لحسابات الجهات الحكوميه والازرق
للافراد والمشاهير كما سيتم التحقق من
جميع الحسابات الموثقه يدويا على تويتر
قبل تفعيل خدمه
[موسيقى]
ازمه تويتر تصل الى فرنسا مع استقاله مدير
فرع الشركه الفرنسيه
لشركه تويتر
على تويتر لكن ماذا تعني هذه الاستقاله
بالنسبه لمؤثرين فرنسيين على تويتر
حول تاثير ما يواجهه تويتر على المستخدمين
تويتر
حتى الان انا الاموره فرنسا
كبيره جدا
على المستخدمين الفرنسيين التويتر في لحظه
ماء سوف يصطدم ذلك بالقوانين الفرنسيه
وسندخل في
الواقع الافتراضي لكن لديه تاثيرات قويه
على الواقع ويقدر عدد المستخدمين
الفرنسيين النشيطين على تويتر شهريا ب 16
مليون مستخدم حتى الان لم تؤثر المشكلات
التي تعصف بالعصفور الازرق على استخدامهم
للموقع فادي الدهوك العربيه باريس
طب اخبار التقنيه ايضا تفاعل واسع شهادته
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي حول العالم بعد
تسريب بيانات اكثر من نصف مليار مستخدم
لتطبيق واتساب منها بياناته لاكثر من 28
مليون مستخدم في السعوديه فقط يعني هذا
التسليم وفقا لمختصين امكانيه استهداف
المستخدمين بالاعلانات وايضا استهدافهم
بالهندسه الاجتماعيه للاختراق وغيرها
استديوهاتنا من رياض ينضم الينا الخبير
التقنيه عبد العزيز محمد عبد العزيز حياك
الله حياك عبد العزيز رقم كبير اكثر من
نصف مليار رقم تم تسريبها تقريبا كل
السعوديه كل ارقام المواطنين والمقيمين في
السعوديه ايضا تم تسريبها على تطبيق
الواتساب
اختراق وتهكير ولا العمليه مقصوده التسريب
بغرض البيع يعني
خالد اليوم ما تم تسريبه هي بيانات جدا
جدا هامه كيف تم تسريبها هي في عام 2019
اغراء في شبكه فيسبوك حاليا استقل لها
المغترقون بطريقه همم يعني احترافيه قاموا
من خلالها يعني سحب عدد هائل من هذه
البيانات اللي تجاوزت النصف مليار
مستخدم هذا ما تم همم ذكره ما الذي حدث في
الكواليس لا نعلم ولكن في ظني انه شركه
فيسبوك اذا ارادت بيع مثل هذه البيانات
ستقوم ببيعها بطرق اخرى لن تتيحها للعموم
على شبكه الانترنت لانه هذه البيانات
اصبحت للاسف متاحه في في وقت سابق على احد
المنتديات المتخصصه في الهكر يستطيع الشخص
الوصول همم لها الشخص المختصر الرسول لها
هذا كمل هائل من البيانات بطبيعه الحال
همم
لانه ملياردير الامريكي اللي هو همم مالك
قال بانه يتطلع الى زياده ارادته عبر خطوه
قد لا تنال رضا بعض المستخدمين لتطبيق همم
الواتساب والماسنجر عبر يعني فرض رسومه
واشتراك شهري على التطبيق يمكن
حمايه مثلا الواتساب لرقمك فانت يجب عليك
ان تدفع رسوم هل ذلك ممكن
لكن فيسبوك ليش جديد عليها البيانات
احيانا تقول وتتعامل مع شركات اطراف ثالث
وتقوم فعليا ببيع بيانات المستخدمين
والكسب من وراءها فيسبوك لا تملك همم يعني
اجهزه لا تملك اي اشياء محسوسه القيمه
السوقيه الهايله للفيسبوك هي قيمه
البيانات وكل ما زادت هذه البيانات كل ما
استطاعت فعليا تزيد من قيمتها السوقيه
تسريبها للسوق سيجعل من هذه القيمه
السوقيه تنزل وفيسبوك ليست بصراحه في موضع
تستطيع تحمل المزيد من خسائر الفتره
الماضيه نزل سهامها الى قرابه النصف همم
خسر او تجاوز خرج من قائمه همم اكبر همم
على مستوى العالم همم
اصبح في المرتبه السابعه عشر فلذلك في
تخيلي فيسبوك تعاني معاناه كبيره جدا في
مساله الحفاظ على همم سريه البيانات
المسربه همم فبالتالي
ايش خطوره هذا الامر عليه
الناس لا يستوعب فعلا الخطر العالي من
تسريب مثل هذه البيانات في راي تسريب
بيانات الارقام السريه وتسريب بيانات
بطاقات همم البنكيه اهون بكثير من تسريب
البيانات الشخصيه لانه اذا تم تسريب
الارقام السريه او بيانات البطاقات
البنكيه بالامكان تغييرها في ثواني قليله
لكن تسريب البيانات الشخصيه لا يمكن
تغييرها البيانات التي تم تسريبها هي
بيانات جدا هامه بيانات ارقام الجوال
البيانات همم اللوكيشنز همم البيانات
الشخصيه للمستخدمين تم تسريب حسابات
الفيسبوك المرتبطه بهذه البيانات بارقام
الجوال تم تسريب في طبيعه الحال كذلك
الدول التي يعيش فيها هؤلاء الاشخاص هذه
البيانات في حال تم تسريبها وقد تم ذلك
سيتم فعليا استخدامها ربما الاستخدام
السيء 28 مليون رقم وبيانات تم تسريبها
مثلا المواطنين في السعوديه سيتم خلالها
التالي على سبيل المثال استهدا هم همم
ربما حملت مغرضه استهدافهم ربما بي يعني
الهندسه العكسيه وانتحال الشخصيات وانتحال
الشركات وسرقه الاموال
تسريب البيانات الشخصيه لاي همم مجموعه في
المجتمع سيكونون عرضه لي يعني الهجمات
التي يعني همم تستهدف هذه الفئه اما كانت
سرقه امواله واما كانت ربما تغيير افكار
واما كانت ربما حتى همم جعلهم همم تجيش
العواطف لديهم بطريقه سلبيه بطريقه باخرى
لانه اتاحت هذه البيانات الشخصيه سيتيح
وصول مباشر
فبالتالي شو المفروض انه كيف اتعامل مع
الموقف طبعا اليوم هذا التسريب بطبيعه
الحال فيسبوك ليس الاول من عام 2018
والبيانات تتسرب عام بعد عام في عام 2018
تم تسريب 92,000,000 عام
مثل هذه البيانات بطبيعه حاسه تجعل
بياناتنا معروضه في السوق همم السودان كان
صاحب التعبير يجب علينا عدم التفاعل معه
الرسائل او همم
يعني التواصل الغريب عدم التفاعل مع في
الواتساب في الواتساب
خلال الفتره الجايه من اشخاص وهميين همم
ممكن همم بغرض الاحتيال ربما في اكثر من
مجال فبالتالي التعامل معها باهمالها هل
يوفر هذا الامر الحمايه ولا يجب عليك كمان
انه انت كمان تتحرك بشكل اكثر همم فقط عن
طريق الواتساب لانه وجود رقم جوالك قناتك
الاساسيه لدى المخترق يستغل اا سواء
الواتساب او حتى الرسائل قصيره او اي
وسيله ربما اخرى لاستهدفك همم لاي غرض من
الاغراض يجب عليك فعليا التنبؤ بل حتى
يعني بطبيعه الحال وصلتك الرساله من اقرب
الاقربين اليك لا تتفاعل معها الا بعد
التاكد من معاييرها فعلى سبيل المثال اي
رابط يطلب منك معلومات لا تتفاعل معه ابدا
همم ما يتعلق حتى بروابط تحميل التطبيقات
وغيره يجب عليه
كمان يعني انت تقول ان المساله ما هتجيء
لك ممكن رقم شخص وتبدا
لانه هو في النهايه الهندسه العكسيه ما
الذي يتم عن طريقها قد يتم اختراق قد يتم
اختراق يعني همم
ارسل للمخترق الرقم السري ب- بهندسه عكسيه
كانه يطلب مني دفع مبلغ معين او غيره
اتفعل معه ويخترق حسابي اتواصل انا معك
اخوي خالد يقول انا عبد العزيز اخوي خالد
لو سمحت تحتاج منك المعلومات الاضافيه او
تحويل مبلغ مالي او تحميل رابط معين او
التفاعل مع صفحه معينه فلن ياتيك من شخص
غريب سياتيك من شخص تعرف نعم فلذلك لا
تتفاعل ويجب عليك فعليا الحذر التام من اي
معلومات او روابط او حتى ربما اا يعني
تفاعل
لن نستطيع لانه سنكون في معزه العالم
تفاعل مع الواتساب في الوقت الحالي ولكن
بحذر عالي خاصه مع تسريب البيانات العالي
الذي همم قد يكون في المستقبل اخوي خالد
الحل وانا شخص يكون عنده رقمين رقم
يستخدمه بطريقه اخرى قد يكون او قد يكون
حتى بعض المختصين يتداول هذه الايام مثل
ما يكون عندنا اليوم عده ارقام بطاقات
بنكيه قد يكون في المستقبل
حمايه في الفتره الحاليه بعد هذا التسريب
بهذا التسريب وصول ارقام الجوالات الى هذه
المخترقين سيجعل من الصعب فعلا الامر شكر
الله شكرا جزيلا لك خبيره التقنيه عبد
العزيز
ايضا في الرابعه بعد قليل منتخبات ستواصل
المفاجات في كاس العالم ايران تهزم ويلز
بقطر على محاك سينغها
اهلا بكم من جديد بدايه الهيئه الملكيه
لمحافظه العلا شمال غرب السعوديه باستقبال
زوارها في عدد من المواقع السياحيه من
خلال انطلاق سلسله من العروض والحفلات
الموسيقيه والثقافيه المتنوعه في عدد من
المناطق المفتوحه منها قاعه ومرايات
والواحات القديمه والمواقع التراثيه التي
تستكشف الطبيعه الجبليه
من احد المناطق السياحيه في العلم مراسل
العربيه اهل الصين هاني مرحبا بك
العلماء اذن على موعد جديد مع فعاليات
متنوعه تنطلق هذا اليوم اعطينا فكره عنها
نعم خالد اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه طبعا بالفعل العلا وكذلك الهيئه
الملكيه نظمتها عدد من الجدول الفعاليات
لهذا العام تحديدا طبعا هناك جدوله لابرز
المواقع التاريخيه وكذلك التراثيه كاضافه
الى الفعاليات للفنون الثقافيه وكذلك
الغنائيه ولكن قبل ان نتحدث عن هذه
الفعاليات تحدث عن المنطقه التي اتواجد
فيها وتحديدا هذا المبنى وهذا المركز الذي
يخصص لمركز للزوار وهو مركز زوار يستقبل
السياح الذين يرغبون بالتجول الى الحجر
منطقه الحجر المليئه بالمواقع التاريخيه
وكذلك المواقع التراثيه والتي يتواجد فيها
اكثر من 110 من المقابر النبطيه وكذلك
مساحتها تت ال 50 هكتار طبعا هناك عدد من
العربات سواء العربات التقليديه كما
نشاهدها وكذلك هناك مركبات تعمل بالطاقه
النظيفه وكذلك مركبات هي مخصصه لمركبات
سفاري وايضا الحافلات تقوم بنقل هؤلاء
السياح بحسب اختيارهم الى الداخل لمشاهده
هذه المعالم وهذه المواقع التاريخيه بينما
نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه سوف نقوم بالصعود
على واحده من الحافلات او من العربات
التقليديه وسوف ايضا نقوم بمشاهده هذه
المعالم اذا سمحت لنا الفرصه وما تبقى من
الوقت كي نتعرف على هذه المنشات التاريخيه
التي دخلت اليونسكو وكيف ايضا قامت بها
محافظه الهيئه الملكيه محافظه العلا
الحفاظ عليها وكذلك الحفاظ على هذه
المنطقه كي تكون وجهها سياحيه من الوجهات
السياحيه اا السعوديه طبعا سوف نقوم
بالتجول في ممر ترابي محافظ عليه من قبل
الهيئه وهي من ضمن المواصفات التي وضعت
همم حتى لا يتم او لا يتم زفلته الزفله
عليه او كذلك وضع اي بنايات خارجيه حتى
يتم المحافظه على الطبيعه الاصليه لهذه
الطرق طبعا هذه المساحه الشاسيه كمان
نشاهدها الان وتلتقطها كاميرا العربيه هنا
هي لمنطقه الحجر وكذلك نشاهد الجبال هناك
وقمم الجبال التي هي معروفه في محافظه
العلا طبعا همم
الفعاليات الثقافيه وكذلك الفنون التي سوف
تقام هنا في محافظه العلا خلال هذا الموسم
سوف يكون هناك حفل الغناء صيني وكذلك
حفلات همم مسرحيه سوف تقام في
وسوف تقام ايضا مناطق جديده وهي مثل مناطق
المنشيه التي تعتبر هي ايضا مناسبه
للعائلات وكذلك ليو اسياح القديمين من
الخارج بلنس ايضا ان مطار العلا اليوم
اصبح يستقبل رحلات دوليه ليست فقط على
مستوى المحلي ولكن الى ايضا اصبح يستقبل
رحلات من الخارج سواء على مستوى المنطقه
الخليجيه او كذلك دول عربيه ومستقبل يتم
التخطيط للدول الاوروبيه
شكرا جزيلا لك اهل الصيام من همم احد
المناطق سياحيه في
الجوله ممتعه يعني شكرا
نبقى ايضا في اجواء كاس العالم انضم الينا
من
الدوحه مفرد العربيه في هذا الشارع فهد
حياك الله معي اذا المباراه مباراه قطر
مازالت تلعب الان اول شيء كلمنا على
الاجواء اجوا هذه المباراه
رتب امورنا ونيجيك
طيب طيب
اثاره المعتاد من بدايه هذا المونديال
المنتخب اللي كان بعيد عن الترشيحات
المدرب اللي كان غاضب عليه الجميع مدرب
المنتخب الايراني يحمل على الاعناق ايران
فجرت مفاجاه امام منتخب اوروبي قوي ويلز
انتصر المنتخب الايراني في اخر دقائق
بهدفين مقابل لا شيء نتواصل للثاره تعود
كل الفرص لهذا المنتخب طبعا اثاره كبيره
حضور اليوم مباريات كلها جماهيريه لكن
بدات الفرحه الفريق الجمهور الفريق
الايراني والان كما تشاهد في منطقه
الجماهير
يتابعون مباراه المنتخب المستضيف المنتخب
القطري امام المنتخب السنغالي اللي تقدم
اثناء اعدادنا
لهذه الرساله من هذا المكان منطقه
الجماهير الكبيره امام الشاشه العظيمه في
الدوحه خالد شدني همم وانا اعد ايضا انه
بعض الشباب السعوديين
حاملين همم اعلام السعوديه وايضا توسع
ايضا بالشهالات القطريه همم لمسانده
الفريق القطري حياكم الله يا شباب الله
اليوم حضرته من اجل المنتخب القطري في
المنطقه
المنتخب السعودي على الارجنتين وبرده على
ذلك اكثر من رائع للمنتخب المغربي
والمنتخب التونسي في البطوله وان شاء الله
يكملوا لها المنتخب القطري ونتاهل جميع
المنتخبات العربيه
نشوف المناطق كيف التنظيم صاير ما شاء
الله تبارك الله ونشكر قطر على التنظيم
وان شاء الله بكره منتخبنا يجملها وان شاء
الله بالتوفيق القطري ان شاء الله ان شاء
الله يعدلون القطريين يعني كانت المباراه
في مسارهم لين الغلطه باذن الله احنا لسه
بنتفائل باذن الله بالفوز يعني فوز قطر هو
يعني يعتبر فوز المملكه واحنا في النهايه
هذه يعتبر فوز كمان لكل عربي همم راح نسعد
جميعا ان شاء الله تاهل المنتخبات العربيه
باذن الله النصف النهائي والنهايه باذن
الله ليش لا يعني احنا كلنا عرب طموحنا حد
السماء نوقف باذن الله يعطيك العافيه طبعا
هذه الاجواء خالد هذه الاجواء يعني
تشاهد اللي يشجع القطري تشاهد اللي يشجع
ايضا المنتخب السنغالي البرازيلي يكون كاس
العالم برده امسح عيشت نفسها كرويه ممتعه
على اجواء يا خالد من كل مكان جميل
وشكرا لك مفضل العربيه الى الدوحه فهد
الشهير
منذ 20 عاما وطلال الرشيدي يمتهن كتابه
المعاريض والخطابات الرسميه واصبح هذا
العمل هو مصدر دخله سالم الراجحي تاب
[موسيقى]
هنا في حائل مواقع تاريخيه واثريه متنوعه
يتجاوز عددها 640 موقع في مختلف في
محافظات المنقطه ومنذ بدايه العام كانت
حائل هي اعلى المدن السعوديه في عدد
المواقع الاثريه التي اعتمدت في سجل
الاثار الوطني لنحو 200 موقع كان اخرها
قبل اسبوعين حيث سجلت حائل 81 موقعا اثريا
من اصل مئه موقع اثري في المدن المملكه
تنوعت المواقع الاثريه بالمنطقه ما بين
الفنون الصخريه والكتابات بالخطوط القديمه
من نقوش ثمديه ونبطيه وكتابات اسلاميه
واشكال ومباني وقصور مواقع مهمه تحتظرها
حائل مثل النقوش الصخريه في جبه وشويمس
والمسجله باليونسكو والقصوري والقلاع
الاسلاميه في مدينه فايد التي تعتبر
المنطقه الاهم في درب زبيده التاريخيه
بالاضافه الى القناع والمجالس التي تعود
للعصر الحديث
النسيم اول واقدم موقع عشوائي مؤرخ في
المملكه وبنطقه حائل يعود تاريخ الموقع
حوالي 350,000 عام قبل الميلاد
تواصلوا هيئه التراث حصر وتسجيل المواقع
التاريخيه في مختلف مناطق السعوديه حيث
اعتمدت حتى الان اكثر من ثمانيه الاف و500
موقع في السجل الوطني للاثار الامر الذي
يساعد في المحافظه على هذه المواقع
والاستفاده منها المراجع العربي
نعتذر التقرير ليس له علاقه بدن بالخبر
عموما في ختام هذه الرابعه او بختام
الرابعه عادات الكربه
يؤكد عدم وجود خبراء ميدانيين في اوكرانيا
ويستعجلوا الضم فيلاند والسويد الى الحلف
خطه الملياريه لتطوير جزيره دارين شرق
السعوديه تتضمن 29 مبادره
تسريب يهدد بيانات نصف مليار مستخدم
الواتساب منهم 28 مليون مستخدم في
السعوديه
اه شتاء مريء بالفعاليات العلا تبدا
استقبال الزوار حفله موسيقيه ومناطق مفتوح
شكرا متابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]